gsy rose is for you bro all right
ooh n
right n gpsy rose look like an Albanian
mother of two from the
Bronx Gypsy Rose all right top comment
is fire what is it may be out of prison
but she's still serving
24/7 okay so break it down to me you
can't kill your mom if she's
literally what what exactly did did she
do she had to take a bunch of the drugs
she had the munch
Muny so I guess Munch is when you think
a bunch of [__] is wrong with you and
you need to be just convince everybody
you're sick probably believe it yourself
Munch and by proxy is doing that to
someone else so she kept telling doctor
she had I think leukemia would keep
shaving her head literally had her
salivary glands removed that sounds like
no fun for anybody you should be able to
kill your moms in that case I think so
but again can't you claim momentary
Insanity the problem is her and her the
boyfriend who actually killed her for
there's apparently a lot of text
messages where it's like
premeditated but can't you be insane for
the whole time that your mother's
torturing you she's a it's a tougher
thing but it wouldn't NE it' be hard to
say temporary insanity if it's been fair
not temporary insanity but like couldn't
you just be induced didn't you have this
like state of insanity induced by
Decades of treatment or however old the
[__] she was I think that's what you
should be a where were you when she got
sentence bro you could have saved her I
would have saved her you could you could
have the courtroom I would have I saved
Al yeah I said I would have saved it
right there I saved you from getting
[__] raped by some Swedish guy in
your [__]
[Music]
whoa [__] this [__] is so far you
haven't seen this no basically they just
post videos of the sea the North Sea is
incredibly dangerous bro and then they
play this song this is actually our our
boy call him yo Gypsy Rose
yo goes crazy you're right black people
do make everything better cuz y'all
sitting here watching this do the video
with the boats my man why are we looking
at Brian Greenberg so Y at home watching
n no yo JY R looking through that camera
man right I feel connected I feel super
connected I'll kill her grandma her
grandma still alive you need kill
[__] you could see how it would work on
a young impress kid absolutely
wow uh you know boyfriend got life in
prison I don't think that's fair I can't
I don't what did oh yeah I almost asked
well her mom got Justice yeah he's up
dude but that is crazy that he got that
I'm trying to think I was trying to
think so what I was reading I was trying
to think how they got there there was
one text he sent to her where he said
like he has an evil side and he enjoys
killing and he used present tense he
never say I future tense I would
enjoy but that's say [__] talking to a
girl though right I mean that's sexual
talk for them maybe at this point I that
my [__] N9 and a half inches and thick
that's right he didn't say he was Silly
Putty
stretch he didn't say his 4 in
dick to 9 and a half by the foot come on
dude y gota pause that
so factual n but dude stabbed her up
wild crazy like that's a different type
well that was the most New York sentence
I've ever heard my entire life nah but
dude stabbed her up wild crazy because
that is that's more difficult that's
more difficult it's more difficult than
like shooting a [__] stabbing is is
anger and hate but what if but she
deserved anger and hate dude and imagine
he loved this girl she abused the [__]
out of her for decades literally had her
in a wheelchair convinced she couldn't
walk which is crazy made her take uh
cancer
meds y she could walk completely fine
her mother was like you're you're
confined to a wheelchair entire change
to a bed apparently did she get um I
mean I be seeing white parents have
their kids on leashes that ain't a good
idea I think that's a good idea I like
the leash thing why do we give push back
on the leash thing because it just looks
so dog
like okay yeah is that bad I don't know
is that bad we love our dogs it just it
feels like you're dehumanizing a kid to
a dog's level we love dogs I love dogs
but when you got a kid the visual of it
I understand the idea is I don't want my
kid to run but even if like the leash
was attached to your chest and y'all
just like they're together that's
different than holding a leash I that's
actually a [__] great distinction the
leash isn't in your hands if it's just
belt to Belt then it's kind of like one
of those things where you carry the baby
right here you know what I mean just
with a with an umbilical cord you just
thought about this right now yeah this
we should do this Bel to belt is
umbilical cord don't even call it a
leash call the cord
thehm but I also think y'all
underestimate how much white people like
our dogs so when we treat our kids like
a dog it's actually a good thing I love
my dogter be kissing them on the lips
too what I'm saying be kissing your kids
on that is accurate I'm upset my dog
don't kiss me back if I put my nose
close and I don't get a lick I'm
tight I'm like what the hell did I do is
that how you punish your dog though if
your dog poops on the on the ground no
kisses don't make out with your dog for
a whole day K yeah I won't give I won't
give her any love no
kisses [__] you
going all right love you love Jesus
you okay son Shifty just walk through a
wall like the [__] Hawaiian Punch is
it
KO [__] yo L's yo put a put $10 now
price pick goingon to multiply the [__]
out of it if you get all that's right
they're going to match your initial
deposit up to 100 bucks okay simple as
that you go to prize pick you use the
code Schultz priz pic.com use the code
Schultz
SZ they're going to match your initial
deposit up to $100 you put in 100 they
put in 100 you take the aash sing locks
and you generate some real Revenue we
know it's the first of the new year you
spend all your money on Christmas
presents spent all your money on a crazy
New Year party time to get a little bit
more in your pockets and let prize picks
do it for you you want you want to yoh
Ho one time yes one time let's go
[Music]
okay
boom
a better video than this yeah come on
man it's I don't know what you're
thinking sorry I don't know what your
brain has can you just you can text him
can you just text damn Mark why you got
so upset I know was in your brain guys
but you know that that wasn't a good
video I didn't see it I don't know what
the video is windi wi you know what if
you had just been honest and just said I
haven't seen the video to him but he has
seen it that's why seen some of them I
also have seen the main guy singing it
and I listen to that one this one I'm
not doing that and we're not going to
have this I like like watching the first
one I listen to the guy's face doing all
the instruments I like that I like
harmonizing I'm a fan of music okay bro
let me like
music I like music do that's the one I
watch God no exaggeration I drove
through SC if I want to watch a redhead
singing it's Ed Sheeran bro I'm not
watching that [__] Yoo yo was
not that one I don't know what y'all are
talking about but both of those videos
were not it I agree I'm not going to I'm
not going to defend those videos but
once you see the one with a shipping
container start falling off this massive
ship because the waves are so big and
the yo ho is
hoing it's one of the most scary things
you ever experienced in your life you'll
have nightmares about
itm that was literally that was when I
saw the windshield wipers cuz how big
can waves be if the windshield wipers
still attached I'm saying I mean like
what is what what the [__] you doing I
didn't know there was windshield wipers
in the thumbnail I you should have seen
a windshield wiper in the beginning of
the [__] video
like this ain't the
oneing containers falling off I didn't
see the thumbnail no it's got to look
dangerous
bro that's a car and a puddle Yoo
yo I'm find it I'm going
go almost guaranteed 100% bad this is
what you do when you on a [__] toilet
for two hours just watching that yo you
know what F I'm look at Gypsy Rose
Christians let black people run
everything we should at the very least
we're going to be having about
Christians y fine black Christians can
run everything I'm okay with
that Al don't don't disagree with
me how fast until it came up on my Tik
Tok that was for stre CU I knew what you
were thinking can I see this video show
us it's not the one it's not the one it
had windshield wipers did it have
windshield wipers or not there were
windsh wipers in
yours
I didn't clock it I didn't clock it oh
thank God you
did said let's see what's going on over
on Instagram maybe there's something on
Instagram I can look at oh my God black
Christians y'all can run things [__] we
already in debt how much worse can you
make it you know what I mean word all
right yo we know how to run up the debt
boy let's go um listen are you on team
free Gypsy Rose or not oh yeah I mean
she's Free's free so but what's up with
the only fans yeah that's what I'm
saying I need to see the damage from
that
abuse that sounded crazy that sound what
was he trying to say that
sound what was he trying to say he's
trying to say I want to understand the
pain that she went through cuz I'm an
empathetic person highly empathetic and
I want to understand her experience
that's what he's trying to say it just
came out like that beautiful that's what
you're trying to say I promise you
that's what you were trying to say wait
but it was I think no oh cuz I thought I
was going to say she was going to be
suuck in dick crazy went through some
incredibly traumatic stuff that's not
true dude that's not true that's not
what I was because she has no salivary
glands so what [__] good is it going
to
be imagine going you broke my heart son
how how did a [__] with no salivary
glands convince a man to kill her mom
maybe more this one of the most
diabolical Geniuses in the world a girl
that can't suck dick convince a man to
that that man deserve double life that
man deserved double life you know the
dude that killed the mom is still in
prison yeah gypsy's out and then and she
broke up with
him to do welcome to the we need you to
punch Mar inest I need you to punch him
in the chest with your [__] right
hand I understand we all Z one [__]
craziest all get in our head but I need
he said he said he said yo yo yo yo yo
yo yo yo y'all know JY Rose is out of
jail right know she's out of jail we've
been talking about this for 10 15es
still
in looking for the Yo video I'm trying
to find it there's wichet wipers on all
of
them that was crazy bar that was crazy
but her the dude that killed her still
in prison and she got a new husband and
have you seen how the husband looks have
you seen how the husband looks let me
see my man identical she got a new
husband yes identical
I know
that oh [__] the [__] dude come on y you
guys didn't know about this let me see
we didn't know about that thank you
might redeem Press Play It's playing oh
that's just one
picture yo that's weird I mean it makes
sense holy [__] wow so she got him to
lose weight no that's the mom on the
left these are different people bro
what's that one right there they look
like a I'm I even going to say
it some one on the left the mom take any
shots you want to at this Chris yeah
this Chris FY looking ass [__] take
whatever shots you want to oh my God
she's massive yeah dude I mean that's
just [__] terrifying dude I thought
she had a great performance in the whale
one an osar for that I mean she does
have Brennan Fraser's chin yeah crazy
crazy see his license plate who's the
husband goes to pick her up from from
jail get her and his license plate on
the front says Hitman whoa fire but he
didn't do anything that's Stolen Valor
you [__] Sten St Valor bro yeah it is
crazy they interviewed the dude in jail
he's like I don't regret a minute of it
hell no dude he's still standing on he's
like I I did that you killed a monster
dude that's fire yeah I mean I don't
know I think if you do all that to a
child like wouldn't
we Sorry quick thing yeah they treat as
far as we know in jail like child
molesters child abusers the worst right
in jail what about a guy that killed the
child abuser how does he get treated oh
he's a king oh he's a king so he's
getting treated okay out there yeah so I
think it's it's like yeah I'm in jail
for life but like I'm getting treated
well I guess what I'm saying is like if
we know that there's a child abuser out
there right especially to that degree
and then they get killed shouldn't it be
a little less yeah life than murder life
seems I think the only thing I can think
of from what I've read is that text
saying I I know people have murdered
people and they went to jail for like 12
years this guy murdered a child
abuser what should that be 6
months like a child abuser as notorious
as her I think that's 6 months like I I
mean a year good behavior six months
fair enough so if you killed Jeffrey
Epstein oh dude who wouldn't kill
Jeffrey EP if you the opportunity purple
heart but here's the problem you know
who killed Jeffrey Epstein himself
Jeffrey Epstein oh so he's a
hero unfortun the only yo Jeffrey
Epstein became a hero at the end of his
life he killed kill that's my point
killed a rapist yeah dude he killed a
child Master he killed a rapist yo did
that list come out
yet we literally put the pot off for a
day hoping the list would [__] come
out and they dropped this list when does
it come out I got to check I got to Che
when school they don't have a
time